[Music]
God's peace in this house
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to episode 19 of
13 o'clock I hope everybody had a good
holiday yeah we had a good one we did it
was nice so no one - yeah that's right
did we say that in the last but anyway
so this episode we're kind of it's not
really serial killer it's kind of serial
killer and haunting we're talking about
the Amityville Horror right which
probably the most famous quote unquote
haunted house case in American history
I've always liked this case just because
it's an entertaining story yeah there's
a lot behind it in and always used to
love like listening to art Bell and
they'd have the witnesses to the case
you know given their testimony
yeah and it always to me sounded
convincing likes like something really
did go down but we're gonna get more
into it yeah there is also I mean I'm
sure most people know there is a
gigantic controversy about this case
whether it's totally a hoax whether it
was just blown out of proportion or
whatever you have the warrants involved
and whenever they're involved man it
always adds another element to it you
know yeah I kind of begrudgingly
appreciate the warrants because they
were they were entertaining they were
never when they would show up on like
Geraldo and all talk show oh I remember
these oh love those whether or not any
of it was true
you know doesn't really matter they were
entertaining yeah they were entertaining
and I not to say that the original a
medieval horror movie from 1979 or
whatever it was that scared the crap out
of me as a kid yeah it was great book it
was a great movie yeah whether any of it
happened or not we're gonna get into
that yeah we're gonna talk about that
we're gonna see if there's anything to
this yeah well we'll examine the
evidence and then sooner or later the
garbin you means dick
but whatever right well you know it's an
entertaining subject to talk about
yeah and you guys will be entertained
and you know with with our ideas and if
you guys have any ideas you can make
comments but we know this case pretty
well yeah so we actually you've written
about this case into your books yeah
actually yeah my new book that's coming
out which will be out in 2017 it's
called the unseen hand and it's kind of
like a compendium of all different
poltergeist mostly poltergeist cases
some haunting like gray shaded right and
there is a chapter about this in there
yeah and don't give it away I watch
we'll just we'll go through it we'll go
through it in due course okay so now if
you saw the movie or if you read the
book by Jay Anson which came out in 1977
then you will know that the one thing
that is indisputably true about the
Amityville case was that the house at
112 Ocean Avenue on in Amityville in
Long Island was the scene of a mass
murder yeah that did happen that did
happen it happened in 1974 and it was
Ronald butch DeFeo Ronnie DeFeo and he
shot and killed his entire family while
they were sleeping a lot of interviews
with him he's a pretty wily character
kind of weasel like he grew the cross
here to crossbreed junkie and a weasel
that would be Ronnie DeFeo yeah and the
weird thing about the case is that well
now initially they didn't think it was
him because what happened was he shot
them all while they were sleeping the
next day he went to work like normal
yeah and then when he got home from work
then he suddenly ran down the street to
his normal bar that he went to where all
his friends hung out and said my mother
and father have been shot and he got all
his friends to come to the house and
they call the cops and they initially
the cops initially took butch DeFeo into
custody to protect him because butch
DeFeo was saying it was Bob he's saying
it was a moppet which wasn't as crazy as
it sounds none of those guys well and
because some of their relatives I
believe
the mother's uncle or the father's uncle
was um was either in the Genovese crime
family are related to someone who was
yeah so you know not totally outrageous
to say that but you know as time went on
and they questioned him and stuff like
that his statements were very
inconsistent and now some of the cops
that at the time
instantly suspected that it was Hannah
was him but yeah they had they could do
anything about it they had to go through
with the NBA you have to go through yeah
cuz they court it could have been wrong
right but the weird thing well the weird
thing about him is he he's still alive
right yeah he's a president um
they never really determined how he did
it how he did it yeah really what the
motive what like why that particular
there's a lot of theories about it one
of the weird things about the case is
that they were all killed in bed they
didn't seem to wake up which was weird
because he didn't have a suppressor any
they were killed with a rifle yeah their
parents were shot twice each in the back
yeah in the weapon that he used if I
remember correctly is a 444 Marlin
lever-action yes that's correct and I
know that rifle and 444 Marlin is a big
bore long cartridge that's very loud
it's like 44 magnums imagine a 44 Magnum
pistol cartridge on total roid rage it's
four times three andreen has four times
longer than normal 44 Magnum pistol
cartridge it's it's like almost like a
reboot of an antique rifle cartridge
which is there fat and long they don't
neck down you know into a smaller
caliber saying that's it's very loud
very loud hard hitting car that's what
seems odd one it seems odd that the
family that everybody liked it was the
parents who presumably were shot first
and then his brothers and sisters they
off they were all found dead in bed
facedown right you would think that some
of them would have woken up or gotten up
and another weird thing too is that the
neighbors didn't report any gunshots all
they heard was the dog working yeah
no they had a dog named shaggy I believe
being from a
family that loves firearms and stuff you
know I've accidentally fired off a few
rounds indoors oh you told me that my
dad actually yeah well when you're a kid
and you're you know not really paying
attention to something you're doing you
know you're practicing with your new
pistol or something like that and you
have your headphones on you might yeah I
was young but I've also dropped a pistol
before a 380 and it went off when it hit
the ground it was the inside of the
carrying case to at the time that it
happened it was just having to be loaded
in chambers and hit hit and I didn't
even know that that pistol went off it
went crack and I saw some plastic flying
from the plastic box and I said how did
I break that carry you just thought it
was I just thought it came yeah because
it acted as a suppressor
you know 380 is a very small pistol
cartridges now but there are certain
aspects of that case where I don't think
it's as mysterious as you would think it
yeah well as can muffle blaster and and
then the people that would be hearing it
they're in a house also yeah and it's in
the middle of the night and they're
asleep or you know not real alert yeah
and it might sound like a backfire right
yeah I guess the car that happened too
far away and you didn't really register
it yeah yes
what the thing that always struck me as
being weird is the fact that they were
all shot while they were laying in bed
yeah now the thing is the thing is
though is that later on as I got older
I'd hear accounts with people that have
survived serial killers serial killer
attack one of them one of them was a
little girl who got a guy who would
randomly go into people's houses kill
everyone while there you could go into
the master bedroom and kill the Paras
and anyone else usually little kids in
this case and he'd shoot them - yeah
well he did that to one and they would
steal the car and move on to the next
family good well and he was a young guy
well in one case the little girl
survived it and she stayed in bed the
whole time
and it seems to be that little kids will
freeze in place like what she I can see
now you're in a headlock yeah and she
heard the parody they're so scared yes
job to do right they basically try to
hide underneath the covers yeah like
it's like a little kid what do yeah
right so I think that may have been why
some of them were killed you know yeah
killed like that now his there's some
people wonder whether or not his older
sister may have helped I was just gonna
mention that as the years went on butch
DeFeo story changed many times right I
don't think he ever admitted to doing it
all by himself
but some of the versions he told were
that his one of his sister Dawn helped
him or that he the earth and his family
was trying to kill him so he was killing
some of them in self-defense and he only
killed his mother his mother killed all
of them and he had to kill her and you
know what I mean so he's not the most
stable individual as what I'm saying no
and he doesn't tell the truth right and
like I said his story has changed so
many times for all we know he could have
killed the parents while they were
asleep in bed just shot the dad the mom
wakes you know jumps up you know from
asleep he shoots her - yeah and then the
kids are all going what happened what
happened goes go back to bed yeah yeah
no I need your brother say then he comes
right and then he goes to the oldest
sister and she's like what the hell's
going on you know the minute she sees
the rifle coming towards her she rolls
over he shoots her in the back yeah so
it may not be as mysterious yes it looks
even the young kids are just in bed
cowering trying to hide underneath the
covers yeah may have been like that now
and this will be a significant detail
later when we talk about the haunting
but at butch DeFeo trial they were
trying to do an insanity defense not
like this so they were trying to say
that he was having paranoid delusions
that his family chart that he was
hearing voices telling him to kill his
family or that he thought his family
were trying to kill him or what have you
spoiler alert it did not work but um
they think he Pro is probably on drugs
or something like
but they didn't thank you we did heroin
yeah he was a heroin he was a heroin
that but anyway still you went to prison
well yeah marijuana addict there nothing
is that his dad was evidently pretty
damn abusive yes I have heard that also
is that Yousef towards the wife and the
kids yeah and I think that actually
pushed Ronnie over the edge yeah that
would have been I think he just wanted
to kill the dad and then he and I think
he did it kind of at the spur of the
moment and then he decided he had to
kill all the witnesses and try to
absolve myself of doing it yeah I don't
I don't think it was pre-planned I think
it didn't seem to be nothing he came
home late at night high or drunk and
says I'm going to take that sucker out
yeah that's probably exactly what I'm
sure I'm sure we'll never know but wrong
but anyway so he went to prison he's
still there now about 13 months later
house was empty for a little over a year
and then along come George and Kathy
Lutz yeah I like the lessons the Lots is
very interesting now the the house it's
a very large house very beautiful house
which is been iconic it's since been
remodeled they got rid of those windows
because they said so many people were
coming by the garden so it wasn't it
wasn't as recognizable which you know
you can understand but um so they came
across the house and it was selling for
the very cheap price of 80 thousand
dollars which was way below its market
back yeah and it had a little boathouse
in the back and access yeah it was a YES
on a medieval creek or white cool quite
cool house and this is a working-class
family basically didn't like a
construction business writing like that
right and then they had they had three
kids right from they were actually hers
they weren't both of they weren't both
of theirs they were hers more a previous
marriage only but um so now before they
moved in they knew that this was the
defame I don't know if they knew
beforehand or if the realtor I mean cuz
I think the Realtors have to disclose
there's there's the story changes yeah
some people say that they knew before
when they moved in because it was part
of a plot all right yeah is it to make a
book right because you have to get into
the rani two favors attorney yeah he was
involved in some of this - I don't know
when you want to get it into that yeah
we'll do that later do that I'll talk
about the hottie in the standard story
first and then we'll talk about the all
alternative story yeah but their story
was that they were told that the house
was the scene of the famous DeFeo
murders that six people had been
murdered in there and they said that it
didn't bother them right because you
know the house was so cheap so they
moved in in December of 1975 now they
only stayed famously for 28 days before
getting the [ __ ] out of Dodge
right because they claimed that the
house was hot yeah and I mean the list
of stuff that happened now initially
they they had and this is another kind
of controversial thing they had a
Catholic priest come in and blessed the
house yeah trying to clear it trying to
clear it out now this was before
anything weird happened right but George
Lutz was not a Catholic I believe he was
a Methodist but Kathy Lutz was a lapsed
Catholic she wasn't really practicing
right but they thought it would be a
good idea cuz people had gotten murdered
in there and stuff like that now the
story goes and this is how it goes in
Jay Anson's book that when the priest
came to the house on moving day to bless
the house and in the book he's called
father man Kuzco I think but that's not
his real name his real name is father
pecker ro or pecker arrow or something
like that they changed his name for the
book but um he said that when he went
into the house he went up into the
iconic room with the little quarterman
sewing room I think well he well what
happened was he went up there um and
heard a voice tell him to get out just
like in the movie wrists like I said
I just put at the beginning of the
podcast there and he says that he did
not tell the Lutz's that he had heard
the voice upstairs at the time he just
told them don't make that a bedroom okay
but later on it it was even questioned
whether he even came there okay like
there was a lot of different because in
the movie obviously they showed like the
room filling up with flies and all this
other stuff and that that didn't happen
right but he said he did hear a voice
but then later on in another interview
he said oh I never even went there I
just talked to them on the phone okay so
I don't really know he showed up but in
the book he did now so after that during
the 28 days they were there they had all
kind of crazy [ __ ] happen and the book
in the movie according to George Lutz
were fairly accurate they said that it
was you know obviously blown a little
bit out of proportion because it's a
movie but most of the stuff you saw in
the movie they did claim to have
happened okay um they did say George did
start waking up and 3:15 in the morning
which they kind of implied in the book
in the movie that that was when the
DeFeo murders have happened but I don't
think that the coroner ever established
a concrete time of death because they'd
been dead so long before they were found
so you know I don't think that it was
exactly 3:15 or whatever but that was
that sounded good in the books as well
yeah so 3:15 he would keep waking up and
stuff like that
and um he also just like in the movie he
was always cold he was always like
stoking the fire he could never he could
never get warm and the house was
actually even though it was wintertime
it was December when they moved in there
were just you know swarms of flies or
we're not just in that room they said
they were kind of everywhere and which
was unusual because it was very cold
outside now Kathy Lutz also started
having nightmares about the murders
which isn't terribly paranormal I mean
if you moved into a house where you knew
that all of these horrible things that
happened you might probably there's a
better I mean I probably would but um
they also noticed that their kids
started sleeping on their stomachs which
I guess they hadn't done before right
kind of like the kids who had gotten
shot um Kathy also said that she would
feel like arms around her yeah she's not
late in the race yeah like not
aggressively but like actually kind of
in a loving way was just kind of creepy
there was the hidden room yeah then
there was the red room which the book
and movie portrayed is being like behind
a stone wall and it wasn't on the house
plans and stuff like that now later on
it kind of came to light that it
actually hadn't been behind a wall it
was just a little alcove right down in
the cellar yes it was painted red yeah I
think was a toy room what yes they just
yeah they just used it as that's what
the old people who lived there before
said it was you know before they did
said that that was not the Lutz's
I think that we know nothing defeos I
think it was already painted red before
the defeos moved in there I believe it
was yeah and then it was it was a toy
room
yeah really distort toys and it was
painted red yes that was the paint that
they had yeah they just said we painted
at that color because we had some
leftover red paint
rose put it on the wall you know so you
know they said there wasn't anything
sinister and these are the people that
lived there before the defeos lived
there yeah another leftist said their
dog I think was affected by that yeah
they said the dog really didn't like it
but like I said I'm pretty sure it
wasn't like behind the wall because you
know in the movie they showed George
Lutz like knocking the oh yeah because
the dog kept digging at the wall again I
heard it described later on and I booth
I don't remember who did who said this
it may have been one of the Lutz's
what's his name is again the the father
George yeah I think George Lutz said
that it just had a normal door jamb it
was just a closet but the door was
missing yeah and that's how he described
it alright it wasn't something that was
that you had to tear down stones to get
to to get to
which of it I mean made it scarier in
the but yeah that's a better way and I
actually I bet I found some pictures of
it so I'll put that in the YouTube video
which it doesn't look super sinister
they also started to notice like I said
cold spots they also noticed weird
smells around the house perfume vile
[ __ ] that stuff like that um George
would hear the front door slamming open
and shut and then he would go down there
and it wasn't like nothing was different
hmm he also said that he heard something
that sounded like an orchestra tuning up
yeah I remember him I remember him
saying that yeah that he would hear that
downstairs and then he would go
downstairs and everybody not being there
he also they said they also sell like a
demon face like in the fireplace like
burned into the set like yeah the back
which they kind of put in that movie
tail and because there was that whole
thing where and they went into this in
the movie and I guess I don't I can't I
guess I can kind of see it it was that
George and butch DeFeo kind of looked
alike yeah like I said it's the 70s
everybody had this porn stash is like
you know it's like yeah I was like do
they look like I don't know I can't
really tell I tell you that they kind of
do the the movie I saw it when I was a
kid the movie has a certain charm to it
it's really yeah I really like that
movie like I and not too long ago I saw
the remake which I think was made in
2005 something like that and it actually
wasn't terrible um it wasn't great but
it you know it they exaggerated a lot
more like with them seeing the ghost of
the little girl which nobody ever
claimed to see that no but um the
original I think the original is a
classic yeah there'd be like trying to
reshoot the Exorcist you can't refute
that you can I'm sure they'll try it
yeah but it would just make it worse
yeah it really did I mean it was kind of
one of those things where you kinda had
to see it at the time yeah it's like the
whole contest 79 feel and the context of
the time and the way society was when
that first came out it was just perfect
yeah
you wouldn't understand if you weren't
there yeah I mean obviously you know
like yeah I was a little kid when that
came out of that I saw it on TV and it
scared the [ __ ] out of me oh my god it
was so scary when I was little and I was
like I'm
no movies anot one really creeped the
[ __ ] out of me yeah but um since we're
talking buds now also one of Cathy's
children Missy the youngest daughter she
apparently started to have an imaginary
friend the enemy Jodi yes now in the
remake
they made Jodi one of the DeFeo kids
that got killed but that's not accurate
they didn't have a kid named Jodi what
Jodi was was a pig yes walked on two
legs yeah that had red eyes sometimes it
was the size of a teddy bear and
sometimes it was as big as the house
biggest the house awesome yeah you okay
yes see last week's show for a breath on
soccer but um yeah so actually I think
that scared me more than anything when I
was a kid zebras like a giant pig like
walking around the house so and this pig
was apparently saying why Pig I don't
know is a pig creature that but he
walked upright horse she I guess Jodi
could be either thing yeah but it was
apparently seen a couple of times now I
kinda see they claim to have seen it
Kathy Lutz said that she looked out of
Missy's second-floor bedroom window and
saw red eyes looking back in it
um George and I believe this happened on
Christmas Eve or Christmas Day he was
out in the boathouse at night and he was
coming back to the house and he looked
up at Missy's window and he saw Missy
standing in the window with a big pig
creature behind her he said he's some of
that and also they said that one morning
they went outside and there were big pig
footprints in the snow
okay like outside Wow although that
can't be entirely accurate because geeky
pedantic people have noted that the day
they claimed to have seen that in the
book there was no snow I have a feeling
that the eyes at the window I have been
a cat all in the windows oh that's what
I'm thinking because and here's like a
brick when I was little I was maybe six
or seven years old and I was sleeping in
my room and I woke up and it was kind of
in there and I looked at my window and
there was red eyes in my window
and I lost my [ __ ] well I screamed for
my mom what was it I don't know okay
well cuz I ice cream for Mom
it was like something out that my dad
got the gun and like went around the
house that's what he said he said yeah I
was probably a record I was like now it
was Jody
it was Jody he got mad and he came to me
so that's going by fast it is yeah okay
um what else we got yes so like I said
you know George and George started to
notice that he was looking more like
butch DeFeo and then he he was starting
to hang out at the same bar down the
street
which the book said was called the
witch's brew but that's not actually
what it's called it's called something
else but I came over what but you know
so and also Kathy started getting
attacked like apparently she floated out
of bed a couple of times she started
developing these red welts on her chest
and George Lutz reported that on at
least one occasion he turned toward her
in bed and she had turned into a 90 year
old hag yeah like she had gotten really
older Hera Donald white yeah I remember
on art bell he said that happened on a
couple that's what I thought it had it
took a while for to wear off
which that seems like like honestly and
you know full disclosure I kind of think
most this story's [ __ ] we haven't
gotten that far but that seems like so
weirdly specific yeah yeah like you took
you know like what if I turned over and
you look like a boo I don't wanna things
like that would creep me out if I turned
over and you look like a big big bridge
troll or something I already do look
like a bridge troll you do cuz I know
you don't
okay and so also they had a lot of
trouble with the locks in the house like
the door
the windows they would they would break
or you know on you know unexplained also
they saw now in the movie at the end
they said like that black goop like
coming out of the walls and out of the
toilet and stuff like that actually in a
book they claimed it was green and it
never came out of the toilet although it
came whose and out of the walls a couple
times yeah and the book did they ever
take a sample of course not of course
not they never did what would have what
what supposedly happened to this green
stuff did it just evaporate away see I
don't think they ever said that either
they just said oh it was running down
the walls suspect okay
yeah else and you know that part at the
end where he was you remember like at
the end of the movie when he ran back in
to get the dog and you felt a many fell
into the goop in the sense he said yeah
that's although I have to say that the
Lutz family and as far as I know they
said because most murmured ed now but um
well the George and Kathy yeah yeah they
didn't live long that's fine yeah they
died did a young guy pretty young yeah
but um they you know they they said that
the thing that kind of that last night
when they were there like in the movie
it was very dramatic and the door and
flew off the hinges and all this other
[ __ ] um but they never really specified
what and what had happened on that last
night that made them get the [ __ ] out
yeah I think they left that open they
said they didn't want to talk yeah they
said oh it was too frightening and we
don't want to talk about it you know
what I mean and maybe they did that just
to like leave some misery you know so
the whole story was well some people
surmise that maybe maybe he got
possessed and tried to kill the family
so they got out there yeah and he didn't
want to admit the fact that he got
possessed and tried to kill a family
yeah cuz that would have been a good
that would have been a good twist on the
story he almost got possessed by the
devil and he seemed the same way Ronnie
DeFeo did yeah tried to kill his family
but he was stronger to resist it yeah
cuz they did I mean that was kind of was
a Conor actually that was the direction
that the because but I think that was
implied more for like the book purposes
or the case purpose and then they
changed they made an ending for the book
of the move
yeah because yeah in the movie they did
cuz didn't he have dreams about cutting
up his yeah and stuff like that like his
nose that was that great scene that and
actually this is one of this seeds other
than the Jody one that scared the crap
out of me where he was having the dream
that he hit Kathy in the head with an
axe and like split her head open I don't
remember that you don't have to shoot
this movie again oh my god that scared
the [ __ ] out of me yeah cuz I've always
been like super scared of like axes and
like beheadings kinda crap so so that
like really disturbed me that scene I
still remember it but they also said
that they heard voices like they they
tried to bless the house themselves like
they went around reverse' fixes and
blessed that sounds I've grabbed a bra
and apparently they heard a voice saying
will you stop but yeah so actually let's
take a break right now cuz we're right
at the show that's why the reported
phenomena more or less more or less and
then so we'll take a break right now and
then we'll come back and we'll kind of
talk about what happened in the
aftermath of it okay alright so we're
gonna be back in just a few minutes
Podcast the brands [ __ ] and heavy metal
properties with a common connection
brought you by hosts token jump drug max
max
smoking Lord Hades and Mars real
Mordecai featuring interviews and more
with the stars of Medellin flora the
necro casting on Mondays if you're into
cosplay corsetry steampunk gothic or
rockabilly clothing shoes and
accessories then you must visit
subculture corsets and clothing either
online at www.haddadtoyota.com code 13
o'clock and receive a 10% discount on
your entire order and if you're a
full-figured girl don't worry subculture
carries sizes for through 4x and they
have men's clothing as well that's
subculture corsets calm and use discount
code 13 o'clock for a 10% discount go
check out their website now subculture
corsets calm or when traveling through
Jacksonville Florida stop in and check
out their store at the Avenues Mall
[Music]
defensive and devaki superchip pro
wrestling in the high spot featuring
interviews with an up-and-coming in this
superstars that are stable that shoots
while it works you can only hear them on
the project entertainment
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone there's a brand new podcast
starting on December 1st the Dead TV
podcast where we take shows from the
horror industry that had been cancelled
or ended and review them episode by
episode starting with kindred the
embraced and Constantine you know out to
stick around and see what the third show
that we're doing immediately after those
joining me for this amazing new podcast
is mister Zenica hello everyone thanks
for having me
mr. Seneca is an event hostess of kinky
geeky and sexy parties around the
philadelphia area she has a flair for
the dramatic and is passionate about
zombies she also teaches on a wide
variety of BDSM topics including hi
protocol in fact you can say she wrote
the book on it which you can find at her
L website WWL kentucky.com thanks so
much I'm happy to be here chris is a
longtime horror fan and turn that love
of horror into an almost decade-long
radio show called radio of horror he
wrote a children's Halloween book in
2012 called give me something good to
eat and has a comic book forthcoming or
he gender swaps the entire counts of
Dracula looking forward to that on the
side he also makes sure horror films in
Massachusetts so how could I say no and
you can get all the updates about our
podcast on our Facebook page
the dead to you TV podcast and
eventually a forthcoming Twitter page as
well so stay tuned for the first episode
coming December 1st
there are terrors real and imaginary and
I write about them all paranormal
nonfiction go to WWJD AFRICOM or search
Amazon for the Jenny Ashford author page
okay so now all of this [ __ ] happens
like I said they left the house in
mid-january they were only there for 28
days are they yeah they were there for
28 days and they left all their [ __ ] in
the house they took off they got their
dog they check out they went to Kathy's
mother's house now in the book they said
that the phenomena followed them to the
mother's house but they didn't really
specify any part what happened right
yeah and like I said the last night they
were there they did they wouldn't really
specify what exactly it happened or why
you know why this one thing it like made
them leave when this [ __ ] had supposedly
been going on for 28 days or whatever
now after they left and the Warren's had
gotten involved with this too although I
don't think they came to the house until
afterward right yeah and I don't think
they were in the book in the movie or
the book they didn't mention them now
but there are pictures of them in the
house right yeah and confirm that they
investigated yeah they were there it was
a lot of stuff after this haunting that
happened let mean even had a TV special
about this house remember yeah they did
a seance in there
yeah live live TV I believe it was long
yeah which yeah which kind of makes me
suspect the veracity of the story and
there were people going in there with
cameras to investigate it and taking
pictures in there and there's
famous pitcher what looks like a little
boys had peeked around a corner yeah
yeah and the Lutz's didn't have anything
to do with that they weren't in the
house at the time yeah they had left
that was I believe a professional ghost
hunting team yeah came up with that
photo very suspect yeah and what makes
it even more suspect is that I mean
pretty much now J Anson the guy who
wrote the book on which the movie was
based later on he actually never spoke
to George and Kathy Lutz in person but
they made about forty five hours worth
of recordings and that's what he used to
write the book from now if you see I've
seen a lot of interviews with George and
Kathy Lutz they don't seem like they're
bullshitting and he didn't change his
story I mean for years and years I give
to the credit they they step to that
story they really did but there are a
lot of iffy aspects to this case no tell
me what's a happy well here's the thing
now Ronald the feyo's defense attorney
that's where it really starts to get
Webb William Weber was that his name
yeah you started starts raising raising
some warning signs right there when when
defense attorney gets involved in this
yeah yeah now he claimed that the whole
thing was a fabrication that he and
George and Kathy and had a meeting drunk
a bunch of wine and come up with this
story to make some money yeah and also
there was an author involved - yeah
Jansen like I said yeah and also to
bolster defense Affairs defense because
they wanted to claim that there was some
kind of evil force in the house maiden
dude that made him do it
amazing bond yeah the devil made him do
it the fence yeah and you know so like I
said the attorney came out later
actually it wasn't even that much later
it was only about a year or two after
the book came out yeah he came out and
said yeah we just made that all up yeah
when you have some [ __ ] like that go
down in a paranormal story you can
pretty much throw it out yeah and you
have a witness or you know at the center
of the case come out saying no we made
all this up for money yeah you can
pretty much throw it out yeah that's the
sad thing about this case yeah but the
Lutz's really did stick to that story it
really you know they sound kind of
compelling which kind of shifts it back
towards maybe something did kind of
happen and they just just blew it out of
proportion there's no way to know but
here's the thing
think of how easy it would be what if
you and me bought a house were a very
high-profile murder had taken place
right and we got four super cheap and
Aulus I mean what's kind of the first
things like hey let's make a bunch of
money rah and we'll say because people
would believe that [ __ ] was on it but
you know what here's the here's where
that thinking breaks down they got a
good deal on that house they they ran
from it without paying for it that's
true left a lot of their stuff in there
although they went back later and got it
oh yeah okay yeah but they defaulted on
that house and they really didn't make
that much money off that book off that
story about more than three hundred
thousand three hundred thousand okay I
thought was a fraction of that
so they profited well that's how much
they admit it to so they profited off of
it yeah that's how much they admitted
they made it might have been more
because here's the thing I was under the
impression based on the interviews that
it was like ten thousand no twenty
thousand no okay so they made a pretty
good mom they had money to three hundred
thousand three hundred thousand yeah I
didn't remember so it was probably more
than five million
it might have been I mean that book sold
and that movie did really well and
actually that whole I don't know if they
would have got money for all that
because that moved that movie like
that's fine
like a franchise they made like a ton
but like the ones now are kind of shitty
they're just like direct-to-dvd but they
made a [ __ ] ton of those movies I think
it's likely there's a hoax because the
people at the center of the case said it
was a hoax so that's very likely that
it's a hope I'll tell you what it's a
damn good story it is it is a damn good
story now one of the things that really
makes me think that it was a hoax is
when you just look at the look at the
case and the evidence that they
reportedly witnessed if you really
analyze it it does not fit poltergeist
phenomena there's no young focus there's
no expectations of object or operations
there's no objects actually physically
be moved by telekinesis you know it's
nothing like the I think the only
actually there was maybe one um there
was there was a couple instances of that
and I think I forgot to mention earlier
one was like some of the crosses they on
the walls would turn upside down yeah
and also um one time George said that he
was walking through the living room and
a little statue of a lion that they had
like appeared like under his feet yeah
and then no I mean later he said he had
bite marks on his ankle it's not enough
to be a classic poltergeist case what
they're describing is something more
like a demonic haunting yeah an
interactive demonic type haunting or but
some people call it a demonic
infestation whatever that is yeah that's
what they're describing yeah
now the wards are involved or they get
involved in it later and of course you
know with with Ed Warren he was a
demonologist yeah all right if he saw
something he was gonna say it was a
demon yeah you know just ed shows up its
demons automatically that's what he's
gonna say because that's what you say
when you're demonologist yeah frightened
but yeah so it's a great it's a great
case I believe it to be a hoax yeah and
like I said there are really more things
pointing to it being a hoax than not and
I'm willing to give them that maybe some
weird will
maybe some doors close by you know maybe
it was like maybe it was creepy in there
maybe it was yeah I mean you know people
got murdered in there that's pretty
creepy and you know maybe it was just
low level [ __ ] like what happens at our
house like the TV came on by it comes on
by its own Oh tell about that talk about
the sponge oh listen to this [ __ ] you
guys this just happened the other day
speaking of poltergeist activity yeah we
have it every now and then you know I
was a poltergeist focus when I was a
little kid yeah go with some girls back
we have a show about a mammoth mountain
poltergeist yeah done lots of podcast
shows on it but so we so every now and
then we still have like weird [ __ ]
happen in our house like I said the TV
comes out by itself align it [ __ ] like
that
I was cooking what was that good um you
were cooking we were making a pan pizza
warming yeah I mean the pan pizza I was
totally focused on what I was doing
yeah and you had your back turned and I
was looking at you
I took the stone out of the oven took
the stone and they haven't put it on the
counter yeah and then all of a sudden we
heard this really loud boom yeah like a
really loud yeah noise like that yeah
it's coming from the direction yeah I
know where that stone was yeah it was
come from behind she just um yeah yeah
took a pizza stone out of the oven it
was hot but it wasn't all that hot yeah
200 degrees maybe the time that I took
that stone out yeah I wasn't gonna use
that stone make it a pan pizza
newscaster I bet so I put that stone on
the counter and I heard some go bomb and
I turned around looked at it this is
that crack that's what we thought cuz it
was so loud yeah and I'm looking at it
and then tell what you saw and then he
had just thrown like a frying pan he had
fried some vegetables and he just put it
in the sink and in the sink like on the
frying pan there was a little dish
sponge that had not been there before
yeah so what happened was somehow I put
the stone on the countertop near the
sink turn around hear it go boom and
then I look down in the sink to say what
was there you go that's not it
you said look at that and I looked in
the sink and there was now a dried
sponge now a sponsor this got scour and
paddle once
on the other it's dried and it's in the
frying pan and that wasn't there before
no cuz he had just put that in this I
picked it up and dropped it and it made
a similar noise but not but not as loud
I tried to throw it into that pan to
make that bong sound and couldn't do it
and it was just like the just like the
TV the TV remote yeah cuz we don't know
where that sponge came from no yeah
because nor we keep to buy the sponge
but there were - yeah maybe on the side
the two were on the side so how does
something I don't know why I don't know
where that third one came prints like it
would have to falling from the ceiling I
think it's somehow just kind of
teleported a few inches off of it and
hit but you never catch it in the act
no we just heard the noise and turn yeah
weird okay good I mean that's a pretty
common poltergeist thing yeah it is
louder than its louder than it should be
right
but um so yeah like we were saying the
the Lutz's did actually benefit from
this the book that Jansen wrote sold
over three million copies and the movie
you know with Margot Kidder and stuff
like that made over eighty million
dollars and the Lutz family I mean after
the book and the movie came out you know
they were all over the media like
talking about their story and stuff like
that which you know I don't begrudge him
trying to make some money off him if it
really happened yeah you know sounds
like it was set up between the lawyers
and an author and them and they were
gonna they were gonna make us cash on
this story yeah and help out help out
old to fail yeah and that I think that
was the whole and actually they were
trying to get him free they were trying
to get him a lighter sentence or put him
into other insane asylum and because
they didn't want him going to prison for
life it was like I said it didn't work
out and I think even butch DeFeo as
nutty as he is and all the you know [ __ ]
he came up with to absolve himself of
what he did I mean even he said yeah you
know the lawyer and you know so what
like I said whether it really happened I
don't know and there seems to be a lot
of this kind of [ __ ] going on with
because I think actually in the in the
book I'm writing
this mmm I kind of merged this story
with the one about this new Decker
family so Haunting in Connecticut
oh yeah that's another movie out of
because the story yeah it's very similar
because the Warrens were also involved
in this gun and it was same kind of like
demonic kind of [ __ ] yeah and they you
know they ended up making a movie about
it and the family made a bunch mark it's
a good story very very questionable yeah
I wish these two cases those two cases
were true but I don't think they are no
like I said I don't think so either even
if like a little [ __ ] just happened the
house like a little door slamming right
like that there's a lot of stuff in
common between it too and it's just the
cases are too good to be true
yes man yeah well and they and I think
we discussed this on the man with
mountain poltergeist case that
poltergeist phenomena don't really tend
to follow a plot it's just kind of
random [ __ ] well they're not claiming it
to be classic poltergeist er that's
wearing it to be some kind of a demonic
interactive haunting that's making
people who's shaken people do things and
there's light and and in the way they're
describing a demonic demonic interactive
haunting they're they're contaminating
it with things with incidences there are
things or phenomena that happens usually
in poltergeist so they're kind of
merging the two although there are some
cases that seem to be pretty good where
the two phenomenons are kind of merged
yeah to a certain extent there's the
snedecker case the one that's the one
that was in the funeral home yeah kid
with the cancer it's a good story yeah
it has a lot of elements of Hollywood
elements in it yeah it'd be neat if that
did happen but I'd have to do a [ __ ]
complete investigation on my own what's
actually out there about that case that
I don't know every aspect I just know
the official story yeah the one that
they put out yeah but I think there's a
lot more to it than that which I'm sure
there is right because that's the thing
you can't really were kids they were
doing the talk
circuit I remember that I remember and
they had people that lived on that
street calm [ __ ] off well because it
must be said that the people that moved
into the house after the Lutz's left
they lived there for at least 10 years
no I'm talking about the coning in
Connecticut oh yeah in that case the
people that lived on that house called
[ __ ] on them saying that they were
hoaxes in it from the very beginning yes
nothing wrong with that house but the
family that was involved with it fought
tooth and nail saying oh no that good
stuff did happen yeah which you know
like I said that was something that was
something that happened in the
Amityville case too is that the people
that moved in after the Lutz family you
know they knew about it obviously
because it was super famous but they
lived there for at least 10 years and
they said nothing weird happened here
they said the weirdest thing that
happens is all the dumbass people
driving by they're like Ben gawk at it
right there gawk at their house you know
what I mean
it also should be said and I think I
mentioned a little bit about this
earlier but that the Catholic priest
that was brought in to bless the house
in the movie it came out because after
the book came out after the movie came
out there were a bunch of lawsuits yeah
between the Lutz's between various
lawyers between publishers between you
know the Lutz's were suing everybody
they were getting countersued and all
this other [ __ ] because of you know just
various things the Lud's is claiming
they were using their name and likeness
without record whatever and you know and
then they would get countersued and all
this other [ __ ] so a lot of these
details came out like in the court cases
afterward now Lutz versus Weber
in which Georgia Cathy sued William
Weber the attorney who apparently who
said that he conspired with them to do
the story
so they actually sued him later so
whether he was just saying that they
that he made the story up with them
because he was mad that they were suing
him or you know they were trying to cast
aspersions on each other I don't really
know but during this lawsuit the priests
who like I said in the book he was
called man cuzco father man cuzco but
his real name is ralf pecker arrow and
in the book pecker aris said that he had
known the Lutz's for a long time that he
had come to the house on moving day that
he had heard the voice blah-dee-blah but
on the stand he said that he had only
met the Lutz's you know a couple months
previous right because they said oh they
oh he knew him before they were married
and stuff like that but he didn't and at
least that's what he said on the stand
that he didn't know them and he also
said that the only thing that happened
was that they the Lutz's called him
right about blessing the house but that
he never actually went there huh so what
so whether he actually lied like in the
book right or whether they just thought
they're just made that up well you know
what they're gonna say the people that
defend the case is saying oh no he went
there he did all that but because of his
vows as a priest he did for
confidentiality and bull all blah and
the fact that he didn't have permission
from the Vatican he's gonna say that he
didn't go but it did happen yeah no it
said what happened is that during the
trial he said that nothing weird had
happened in the house but then he said
that he wasn't at the house it was like
this huge [ __ ] so we don't really
know I mean he's dead now so you know I
don't really know what the truth of the
matter is but um he got moved to another
diocese later like before he died but he
just later he said nothing happened the
case is pretty contaminated yeah very
contaminated I'd say there's nothing to
it at this point there's nothing to it
other than a really cool movie and a
good book and you can go on you know
like recordings of art bell shows when
the Lutz's are doing interviews and they
do an awesome bit of interview I love
the stories I mean it it's pretty
compelling what they say yeah you know
it's interesting I don't know I don't
think it's true yeah but it sure is good
like I said you got to give him props
for sticking
for that long right and actually didn't
we see this was probably like last year
something like that didn't we see that
documentary that had one of their kids
grown up right and he's kind of nutty
yeah he seemed a little uh yeah troubled
and he blamed it all on George and his
involvement with black magic that he
didn't want to talk about I didn't know
right I didn't know about that
I didn't buy a word of what the kid was
saying oh yeah he was a kid oh good I
don't buy a word of it but it was
interesting to watch yeah it was I wish
I could remember the name of that now
it's probably I think it's on YouTube we
saw it yeah yeah it's one of his
grown-up kids you can probably find it
if you search but yeah he's on Netflix
Oh but yeah he claimed apparently him
and George Lutz who is his stepfather
yeah he didn't like him and he didn't
like him and they didn't get along he
blamed it on me saying he was abusive
yeah so you know who knows and I think
it the I think at the point that this
documentary came out George Lutz was
dead right yeah he's gonna really define
himself
I mean Cathleen Lutz Kathy Lutz had been
dead for quite a while at that she died
pretty yes you guys she's got pretty
young yeah yeah no cancer I mean now
they had divorced before she died they
were already divorced yeah yeah cuz okay
that's what I thought but you know at
any rate like I said great movie
it's a classic yeah I don't you know I
don't know how appreciated it was at the
time I just I was just thinking of like
how Stephen King thought it was a stupid
book he's like it's a good movie but
it's kind of stupid what we do yeah
which it kind of is it's kind of a dumb
you know it scared the crap out of me
when I was kid so that was it was good
in his day yeah and the book was good
too I read the book a long time ago but
you know do I think it really happened
now yeah and you know but still good
story yeah he was wrap it up there all
right so we're gonna wrap it up now so
we hope you enjoyed this little
breakdown of the amiable Horrors we went
off our yeah Tana Jason tangents at
least we got to do this case cuz I
wanted to talk about it eventually yeah
we can get it out of the way it's a
famous case and you know we can move on
to better ones yeah later okay so
you guys remember that we still have
t-shirts so go get one is that wwsz soul
calm / 13 o'clock and that'll probably
pretty much do it like I said hope
everybody had a good holiday and hope
everybody has a good New Year's coming
up don't drink and drive
oh go ahead drink up boys
see you bye see you next week bye
[Music]